i
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Değilsin
işlemlerinizin değeri
mevcut değil
Peki
Ah
belki değil
elizondo
[Müzik]
ve
de
nasılsın
ve çok
[Müzik]
Hadi geri dönelim
Anlıyorsun
[Müzik]
ve
Evet evet
Ah
bu zaten
s
ben
fakat
bilmiyorum
Ah
Peki
[Müzik]
ya da değil
ve
şimdi
yapmıyorum
bu öğleden sonra
[Müzik]
tüm yönetmen
İberya
başka bir işaret
kuyu
ya da değil
gordon lish
ve hazır
[Müzik]
bizim için
Evet
çözüm
[Müzik]
Evet
sonra
ama hayır
ve
farzedelim
ihtiyacın var
onun hakkında
[Müzik]
Bakmak
Peki
i
bu konuda kaybetmek
kuyu
[Müzik]
Bilmiyorum
hakikat
HAYIR
ve
Evet evet
tek başına
[Müzik]
rağmen
ve
Evet
ona sahip olmayacağız
ve
Ah
hakikat
bunda
bu bayrak
senin için
şimdi
her şey geride kaldı
Evet
Teşekkür ederim
herkes
aklını söyle
Merhaba
Yahuda
ve
ne kadar ödendi
farzedelim
ve
ve daha sonra
Evet
O mu
D
Teşekkür ederim
i
veya
dır-dir
Ve gerçek evet
olup olmadığını soracağız
artı
farzedelim
bizimkinde
ve
[Müzik]
ve güç
ve
Peki
Böylece
2'den kırmızı
ve
Eğer ben
nasılsın
ve bir kadın
ya da eğer
Evet
genellikle koşarlar
görünüş
Sana söylüyorum, bir sorunuz var
hayır
Evet
değilse
D
Evet
ve
ya da iki
aynı olmasına rağmen
Teşekkür ederim
ne olduğunu
ve sahip
ve
onlarla
Böyle
ve
[Müzik]
farzedelim
ve
bakire
[Müzik]
ve
genelde
Evet
dır-dir
HAYIR
fakat
şimdi
Eğer onu istiyorsan
bu ne
o
sağlıklı
Bu siyah
Ah
D
ve ben
eğer varsa
fakat
Evet
artı
Peki
s
ve
eyalette
veya
Evet evet
onlar vardı
ve
[Müzik]
ve eğer onlar çocuksa
ve ben
Alçı
Eğer birşey
biraz doğru
Evet
ve
kuyu
ve görünüm için
ve sen
o
[Alkış]